bah c'est super sympathique c'est bien
organisé on attend très peu non ça se
passe très bien
beaucoup plus petit que le vaccinodromes
de saint quentin en yvelines
le centre de vaccination de crespières
est l'un des seize complexe yvelinois un
centre rural qui assure depuis le 10
mars un rythme régulier d'injection un
accueil fantastique du des personnes
très sympa des explications parfaite
hier nous étions à 4000 personnes donc
en en six semaines
et à partir de la semaine prochaine nous
allons passer le cap des familles la
particularité a créé pierre hormis les
médecins et infirmiers le personnel
administratif et bénévoles ils se
relaient six jours sur sept de sorte à
être 8 sur place je me suis proposé
cordes quand l'aventuré a commencé début
mars je me suis proposé quand il ya eu
un appel à bénévoles pour notre part
notre
première adjointe moi je fais tous les
samedis tous les samedis matin et si on
a besoin après plus tard pour le samedi
après midi
j'essaierai d'être volontaire également
et puis ça prend quelques heures
également puisque je m'occupe de
également de gérer les tout ce qui est
personnel médical
accueil assistance aux personnels de
santé et même récupération des doses de
vaccins nécessaires à l'hôpital de
versailles un engagement local
inattendue lors de la mise en place du
projet ce qui est absolument
extraordinaire dans notre histoire c'est
que c'est des bénévoles de notre
intercommunalité petites
intercommunalités de 24 mille habitants
et j'ai 150 bénévoles qui se sont
présentés que je ne connaissais
absolument pas et qui ont décidé de
venir à mes côtés pour permettre qu'une
fonctionnement de ce centre
la rs a d'ores et déjà prévu de doubler
les doses de vaccins livrés au centre
400 injections par jour pour une moyenne
de 2000 par semaine